[Music]
gucci is bringing a whole new meaning to
the hollywood walk of fame damn this is
a big deal the iconic fashion house shut
down hollywood boulevard tuesday night
for their gucci love parade runway show
and a who's who showed up and showed out
first let's talk about the models here's
macaulay culkin rocking a colorful
jacket in top with some camel colored
pants jared leto a long time gucci
ambassador and star of the upcoming
house of gucci movie also hit the runway
in an oversized blazer and lace up pants
and check out jody turner smith
delivering a true fashion moment in a
furry coat and turquoise shades
thank you so much but when it comes to
the audience well there was no shortage
of a-listers
gwyneth paltrow caught up with dakota
johnson of course dakota's longtime beau
is gwyneth paltrow's ex-husband called
play frontman chris martin they even
posed for a photo together and props to
gwyneth for looking just as chic as she
did in 1996 when she first wore that red
velvet gucci suit miley cyrus had a
friendly chat with lizzo while it was a
family night for gabrielle union and
dwyane wade
[Music]
yep that's the basketball star and the
actress strutting into the event with
their 14 year old daughter ziya
my
hair but then the waves linked up with
more famous families the johnsons and
the bryants
check out this epic group shot kobe
bryant's wife vanessa and their eldest
daughter natalia smiling next to the
wades and magic johnson's son ej and
wife cookie vanessa shared a bunch of
candid snaps including some selfies a
peek at her front row seat a pre-show
in-n-out burger and even this touching
moment when she spotted a mural of her
late husband
[Music]